chaos in the heart of New York City
thousands of people mostly teenagers
rioting in the streets but this wasn't a
protest they had descended on Union
Square Park after a popular social media
influencer announced he would be giving
away video gaming consoles we will be
giving away
say summon the crowd instigated the
melee by throwing objects and shooting
off fireworks causing the pandemonium
others blocked traffic
police tried to disperse the crowd but
were met with resistance initially the
police seemed to be caught off guard by
the event and how quickly the crowd
turned violent there was a construction
site within within the Union Union
Square Park and people broke into the
park and they began to grow uh articles
that belong to the construction site
paint cans bottles rocks we had people
walking around with shovels uh axes some
in the crowd attacked officers our
officers were attacked uh we were in
there we were we were crushed we were
pushed I had officers on the floor the
influencer is Kai sanat a new york-based
streamer on Twitch who has millions of
followers across various social
platforms late Friday police say he did
not have a permit to hold his event and
now faces multiple charge
including inciting a riot thousands of
New York police officers descended on
the scene as the riot was happening and
regained control in about an hour it's
65 people were arrested half being
juveniles
flash mobs and large crowds for
influencer-led appearances are nothing
new in New York City but in no time in
recent memory has there been anything
quite like this a gathering that has
spiraled out of control so quickly
Gabriel Elizondo Al Jazeera New York